One of the other things I've learned as
a social scientist,
and I've been warned about this by I
would say great social scientists that
you want to be very careful about doing
large scale experimentation with large
scale systems because the probability
that if you implement a scheme in a
large scale social system that that
scheme will have the result you intended
is negligible.
What will happen will be something that
you don't intend and even worse,
something that works at counter purposes
to your original intent and so and that
that makes sense because if you have a
very,
very complex system and you perturb it,
the probability that you can predict the
consequences of the perturbation is
extraordinary low.
Obviously if the system works though,
you think you understand it because it
works and so you think it's simpler than
it actually is,
and so then you think that your model of
it is correct and then you think that
your manipulation of the model which
produces outcome new model will be the
outcome that's actually produced in the
world.
Now it doesn't work at all.
I thought about that an awful lot.
Thinking about how to remediate social
systems because obviously they need
careful attention and adjustment and it
struck me that the proper
strategy for implementing social change
is to stay within your domain of
competence and that requires humility,
which is a virtue that is never
promoted in modern culture.
I would say it's.
It's a virtue that you can hardly even
talk about,
but humility means you probably not as
smart as you think you are and you
should be careful and so then the
question might be,
well,
okay,
you should be careful,
but perhaps you still want to do good.
You want to make some positive changes.
How can you be careful and do good?
And then I would say,
well,
you try not to step outside of the
boundaries of your competence and you
start small and you start with things
that you actually could adjust that you
actually do understand,
that you actually could fix.
I mentioned to you at one point that one
of the things Carl Jung said was that
modern men don't see God because they
don't look low enough.
So very interesting phrase and one of
the things that I've been promoting,
I suppose online is the idea that you
should restrict your attempts to fix
things to what's at hand.
So there's probably things about you
that you could fix things that you know
that aren't right,
not anyone else's opinion,
your own opinion that aren't right.
You can fix them.
Maybe there's some things that you could
adjust in your family,
although that gets hard.
You have to have your act together a
lot.
You can start to adjust your family
because things can kick back on you
really hard and you think,
well,
it's hard to put yourself together.
It's really hard to put your family
together.
Why the hell do you think you can put
the world together?
Right?
Because obviously the world is more
complicated than you and your family,
and so if you,
if you're stymied in your attempts even
to set your own house in order,
which of course you are,
then you would think that what that
would do would be to make you very,
very leery about announcing your broad
scale plans for social revolution.
Well,
it's a peculiar thing because that isn't
how it works because people are much
more likely to announce their plans for
broad scale social revolution than they
are to try to set themselves straight or
to set their family's straight and I
think the reason for that is that as
soon as they try to set themselves
straight or their families,
the system immediately kicks back at
them right instantly.
Whereas if they announced their plans
for large scale social revolution,
the lag between the announcement and the
kickback is so long that they don't
recognize that there's any error there.
And so you know,
you can get away with being wrong if,
if,
if nothing falls on you for a while and
so,
and it's also an incitement to hubris
because you can now see your,
your plans for large scale social
revolution and stand back and you don't
get hit by lightning and you think,
well,
I might be right.
Even though you're not.
You're seriously not right.
I might be right.
And then you think,
well,
how wonderful is that?
Especially if you could do it without
any real effort.
And I really do think fundamentally,
I believe that that's what universities
teach students now.
That's what they teach them to do.
I really believe that.
And I think it's absolutely appalling
and I think it's horribly dangerous
because it's not that easy to fix
things,
especially if you don't,
especially if you're not committed to
it.
And I think you know,
if you're committed because what you try
to do is you try to straighten out your
own life first and that's enough.
Like there's this.
I think it's a statement in the new
testament that it's,
I think it's in the new testament that
it's more difficult to rule yourself
than to rule the city.
And that's not a metaphor.
So like all of you who've made
announcements to yourself about changing
your diet and going to the gym every
January know perfectly well,
how difficult it is to regulate your own
impulses and to bring yourself under the
control of some.
What would you say?
Well structured and ethical,
attentive structure of values.
It's extraordinarily difficult.
And so people don't do it and instead
they wander off and I think they create
towers of Babel.
And the story indicates,
well those things collapse under their
own weight and everyone goes their own
direction.
I think I see that happening with the
lgbt community.
I think because one of the things I've
noticed,
it's very interesting because the
community is in some sense it's not a
community,
but
that's a technical error,
but it's.
It's composed of outsiders,
let's say,
and what you notice across the decades
is that the acronym list keeps growing
and I think that's because there's an
infinite number of ways to be an
outsider and so once you open the door
to the construction of a group that's
characterized by failing to fit into the
group,
then you immediately create a category
that's infinitely expandable.
And so I don't know how long the acronym
list is now.
It depends on which acronym list you
consult,
but I've seen lists of 10 or more
acronyms and one of the things that's
happening is that the community is
starting to fragment in its in its
interior because there is no unity.
Once you put a sufficient plurality
under the sheltering structure of a
single umbrella,
say the disunity starts to appear
within,
and I think that's also a.
it's a manifestation of the same issue
that this particular story is dealing
with,
so that ends,
I would say,
the most archaic stories in the Bible.
There's something about the flood story
and and also the Tower of Babel.
I think they outline the two fundamental
dangers that be set mankind.
One is the probability that
blindness and sin will produce a natural
catastrophe or entice one.
That's something modern people are very
aware of in principle,
right?
Because we're all hyper concerned about
environmental degradation and
catastrophe,
and so that's the continual reactivation
of an archetypal idea in our,
in our unconscious minds that there's
something about the way we're living
that's unsustainable and that will
create a catastrophe and so interesting
because people believe that firmly and
deeply and but they don't see the
relationship between that and the
archetypal stories because it's the same
story.
Overconsumption greed,
all of that is producing an unstable
state and nature will rebel and take us
down.
Right?
You hear that every day in every
newspaper and every TV station.
It's broadcast to you constantly,
so that idea is presented in,
in genesis and the story of Noah and
then the other warning that exists in
the stories.
One is beware of natural catastrophe
that's produced as a consequence of
blindness and greed will say the other
is be aware of social structures.
That overreach because it will also
produce fragmentation and disintegration
and so it's quite remarkable.
I think that that with at the close of
the story of the Tower of Babel,
we've got both of the permanent
existential dangers that present
themselves to humanity already
identified.